don'know beach rookie trying to play
LeBron James now this is a very
difficult cover your success in his
building against Toronto is transition
basketball and the three-ball James
driving the baseline for a slam on her
see he just skips it bacon as he goes by
alright now that to leading rotated all
right things happen here you're gonna
see a nice move here right now just gone
gold right now I'm gonna kick to the
other side wide open man they catch you
to pull that thing out of delay and not
taking LeBron into his number huh live
another day coach yeah I got it and we
hope that he has a quick return and a
healthy one ball their own spots up from
three and gets out a primal yell on the
second leading is this guy in the league
if you haven't seen him play a lot this
year just think about it Westbrook is a
design play that was executed perfectly
James with a quick trigger on the three
and a little bit of get back on light
chains over the Jeff Green was platz up
and he drills a three
let's relax and then blow right by him
and then don't know rotating man see ah
come on James
Prakash inside to Kevin Love
I think that is LeBrons 15 assists that
there was no defender even rotating so
he had 20 of times on the defense
[Applause]
dim nigh this is it see he sees that
priest important now both teams have two
timeouts remaining and no fouls to give
James kicks it out to the corner low for
three closing time
Kevin
[Applause]